attention le jeu est simple une
bouteille d'antibes acariens pouvait
faire ses jeux chez vous un ca coute
rien voilà et une balle de ping pong
celui qui fait le plus de gens on va
démarrer par valérie bénaïm avec plaisir
valérie bénaïm voici votre balle aussi
votre gel attention vous êtes prêt de
beinheim d'arrivée de retour va croquer
tous ensemble attention si tu crois au
lycée jessé il avait alors on va voir
vous pouvoir d'achat soit en c b le
trouble
[Applaudissements]
ne pas s'aimer mais qu'à lourdes et vous
la devinez qui arrivait de money honey
une balle attention à ça c'est bien il
la qualifie avec 1,5 à vorey bah oui
2 pourquoi 4,5
ouais la péta tropicos l attention pour
l'instant c'est kelly vélo v li lé cette
qualité dvd avec cette arme au guidon
avait en fait attention c'est parti on
se félicite pour les 2 3 4 5 6 et 12 13
14 15 16 17 18 finalistes pour la
spirale
maintenant il ya 17 ans bac revenu à
tanger partie hyper concentré dans cette
concentration l'évasion deurne
j'étais en bas du yoga 1 2 3 4 5 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 attend toujours son pick up
et mathieu qui était pas mal julliard
dette
tu peux garder 2 m oui mais attention à
ne pas mettre partout c'est sur l'air
ajouté mais c'est gratuit 3 4 bon c'est
bon mais bon allez merci c'est bon
sophie toast à battre avec 17 jours jean
copycat peut vous sauver benjamin
castadi belgique une deux trois quatre
cinq six dix contre onze c'est sophie
qui est honnête pour la station
et là on a on arrête ou la championne de
badmington oui je vous ai vu les jours
ces 20 minutes
mais bon mes excuses moi au nid d'amour
est bon il ya 17 abate sophie cottes qui
est un final qui peut sauver les
chroniqueurs 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 9 à la
dommage c'était pas mal hattab sophie
tost est au final sorti dans l'axé
sophie attention c'est très sain
sophie store deux histoires deux fois
celui qui fera le meilleur score sur
deux prestations d'accord sur fille si
tu gagnes tu fais gagner je vais le
montrer
tu feras gagner au chroniqueur ce
magnifique regard regarder passer bon si
vous regardez
pour chaque chroniqueur faut chaque
chroniqueur
[Applaudissements]
on additionne les deux dallas est le
meilleur le meilleur soit on a discuté
de la regarde additionnel on additionne
les deux choeurs prends ton à d'ornano
oui bien sûr une part coin oui ah oui
quand-même une rover
attention c'est le saut final équipe à
ces rumeurs aux dames c'est qu'au barça
bâti attente atteint 2,3 c'est parti
range rover 1 2 3 4 5
si leicester à l'appréciation des
dommages à 5 06 13 14 15 9 21 22 23 24
ans 31 32 33 34 35 36 ans
[Applaudissements]
alors avant qu'elle joue il ya 36
sabatier propose qu'on revoie le cadeau
qu'il devait gagner
c'est horrible l'effectif est allé 36 à
battre allait il se plaît allez sophie à
l'eso feuilles sophie respire suite d'un
4 4 a dit qu'avec 1 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
c'est perdu merci ma chérie et oui c'est
perdu des places à côté du cadeau on va
voir dans un instant la personne qui a
gagné le magnifique la magnifique table
est en bien sûr sur les réseaux sociaux
et benjamins malheureusement on se
retrouvera lundi
et oui vous perdez cette semaine mais la
semaine prochaine les balles alors je
vous le dis en revanche puisque vous
avez tous un gage ce week-end vous
devrez tous mettre une photo de vous en
train de faire des crêpes à poil avec
donc une poêle ici pour les garçons et
deux poêles ici et là pour les filles
d'accord merci voilà tombés d'accord oui
si moi j'avais pas si j'avais perdu je
l'aurais fait malheureusement quand on
perd à paris au nord pourquoi le nom de
roller exact merci mesdames vous êtes
prête pour le faire c'est à dire que
j'ai un peu plus d'un mois après sa b2
c'est mal pour ça mais des deux fois
leurs noms mais de poils bien sûr
sociale et la raison